hey everyone welcome back to your daily
equation and today I'm going to address
a question that and kind of asked all
the time in one form or another which
basically asks for instance when do you
have to make use of special relativity
at what speed do you need to use the
equations of special relativity or when
do you really need to use general to do
what math scale do the equations of
general relativity kick in or at what
length scale how small do you have to go
before you need to use the laws of
quantum mechanics and of course I
understand the intuition behind the
question completely we when we learn
about physics we first learned about
classical mechanics and Newton's laws
and then we learn about these more
refined descriptions of the world
quantum mechanics special relativity
general relativity and so forth so you
naturally wonder okay when do I need to
use those theories now the fact of the
matter is in principle you really need
to use those theories all the time in
the sense that those theories they apply
everywhere
at all mass cows at all speeds that at
all length scales the more refined
description that we have achieved
through our monomer search is the right
description but of course you know if
you're if you're plotting the course of
a rocket going to the moon nobody uses
quantum mechanics you could use quantum
mechanics at least in principle but
Newton's laws of motion from classical
mechanics are such a good approximation
that those are the equations that we use
are a much simpler description of a
rocket going to the moon and they're so
fantastically accurate that we don't
need to use the more refined description
of quantum physics which is just to say
when we make progress in fundamental
physics it's rare that we wipe out pass
understanding what we really do is we
extend the domain in which we're able to
understand the world mathematically by
having a more refined mathema
description that goes beyond the earlier
description so Newton's equations work
really well if your speeds are not too
big but when your speeds get larger and
larger the laws of special relativity
become more and more necessary to have
an accurate description the laws of
Newton also work for objects in the
everyday world of course but if you then
try to use those equations to describe
smaller and smaller things the equations
become ever less accurate and you need
to invoke the laws of quantum mechanics
to have an accurate description of
what's going on so that means in
principle given any of our refined
theories general ativy special
relativity quantum mechanics we should
be able to extract the older description
of the world as a kind of special case a
limiting case of the more accurate
description and so that's really what
today's discussion is about trying to
understand in particular how we can
extract the laws of classical mechanics
the laws of Isaac Newton from the more
refined equations of quantum mechanics
in particular the Schrodinger equation
and this was achieved in a number of
ways actually but the first person to
really make headway on this problem was
paul ehrenfest he's this fellow right
over here and in a paper that he put out
in 1927 show a little piece of that
paper right here he showed how Newtonian
mechanics Newton's second law in
particular can be seen as a special
limiting case of Schrodinger's equation
and historically this was a very
important development because it really
helped a whole group of physicists that
were struggling to understand the new
quantum reality and how it interface
with the older classical reality the
reality of common experience in common
perception and with the equation that
ehrenfest
wrote down the
blending or perhaps you should say the
morphing that's a better word the
morphing from Newtonian perspective to
the quantum perspective and going back
from the quantum to the Newtonian became
much more apparent so what I'd like to
do is give you a sense of what ehrenfest
found and I'll give a little bit of the
mathematical derivation for those who
are interested so you can really see how
to link the classical and the quantum so
today's episode then is errand of them
spelling ehrenfest correct ehrenfest
theorem or ehrenfest
equation if you want to fit into our
paradigm if your daily equation which is
unnecessary okay silly after a while
some people in the comics and that's not
an equation that's a theorem that's not
an equation that's that's a statement so
you know we're pretty broad in our
definition of what an equation is here
but I think we're all on the same page
and that so our goal is say to start
with Newton and in particular Newton's
second law which is just F equals MA and
of course the acceleration is the second
derivative of the position with respect
to time and for the force we will focus
our attention solely on conservative
forces forces that can be derived from a
potential energy function by taking
negative of the derivative and therefore
in this form Newton tells us MD 2x DT
squared equals minus DV DX so that is
what we all learn in school very basic
and what Schrodinger comes along with
later on in giving us say the quantum
equation so Schroedinger gives us a kind
of different picture of the world right
so rather than a trajectory of a
particle so you know
if you want to have an image in mind
which is good
Newton says look I have a particle at
some initial time it follows some
trajectory to some final time and at any
given location this is what we mean by X
of T Schrodinger says well that's really
not the right way of thinking about the
world fundamentally speaking instead he
gives the world the equation I h-bar
dasai DT mm-hmm equals minus H bar
squared over 2m d 2 sy DX squared plus V
of X times sy and in this picture of the
world of course you're not looking at
trajectories any longer you're looking
at this probability wave this wave
function called sy it evolves in time so
that might be its shape the pings scuse
me got to take something to drink here
that might be its shape my my muddy
water my real gray that might be its
probability shape at any given moment in
time and from this you can work out
according to max borns interpretation
the probability say that the particle
will be at any given position and the
probability of course is given by the
value squared the norm squared of the
wave function at the given time at that
given location so you know hmm we have
two fairly different ways of looking at
the world here you've got particle
trajectories over here you've got
particle wave functions and
probabilities what is the relationship
between these two pictures and in
particular can we derive Newton's
picture from Schrodinger's the picture
Wow really good stuff in my throat here
today sorry about that
so so how are we going to do this well
there is a notion of position in quantum
mechanics
not that quantum mechanics does away
with the notion of position it's just
that if you measure the particle at any
given moment of time let's say at time T
we know that what the wave description
over here is telling us is that there
are many possible outcomes so you might
find a particle at position X 1 or
position X 2 position X 3 and so forth
and indeed if you ran exactly the same
experiment with exactly the same initial
shape for the wave function he ran it
over and over and over again you would
indeed at a given time T find the
particle to be at many different
locations in those many different runs
of the experiment let me just show you
that one in a visual bring this up here
good so here is an undulating
probability wave and the height of the
wave or more precisely the norm squared
of the wave gives us the probability of
the particle being at the given location
underneath that portion of the wave and
if I measure the particles position boom
I cause the range of possibilities to
ante up to pick one definite location
and the wave spikes at the location
where the particle is found my point is
if I then run this exact same experiment
over and over again and measure the
particles position at the same moment in
time say the same duration from the
start of the experiment like you know 10
seconds after the experiment begins I
will find the particle at different
locations that's what quantum mechanics
is really telling so let me run this
experiment again the wave is undulating
and let me measure it it's a time 10
seconds and you see it's at a different
location than I found it before on this
experiment II but a third time the wave
is undulating same probability wave
measure it again 10 seconds from the
start and I find it at a third location
still so how then do we turn this range
of possible locations at a given moment
in time into something that at least
resembles the notion of a trajectory
that changes over time and there is a
technique for doing that within quantum
mechanics which is to consider what we
call the average value of the position
of the particle at a given moment in
time we simply take the range of
possible places where it could be at
time T and we do a weighted average of
those locations by the probability that
the particle will actually be found at
those individual locations so we simply
sum for all possible positions where the
particle could be found the probability
that the particle is at that position
multiplied by the value of the position
itself now two things first we have an
expression for the probability it just
comes from the norm squared of the wave
function second we're looking at a
continuum of possible locations and
therefore our sum should really be
written as an integral which is just a
fancy version of a continuous sum so we
can look at the integral from minus
infinity to infinity sy star of X sy of
X multiplied by the value of X
integrated with respect to X so that
gives us a notion of the average or
expected location of the particle at a
given moment in time and then with that
in hand we could ask ourselves questions
like well how does that average position
change as a function of time that is
what is the derivative of the average
value with respect to T and of course
once we understand that we could take
one more derivative what is the second
derivative of the average value with
respect to T and what we will find or I
should say more precisely what paul
ehrenfest found is the following
he found by evaluating that expression
he found that
md2 average value of the position with
respect to x squared is equal to well if
it was Newton we want to be something
like minus DV DX but this is quantum
mechanics so indeed he found that it's
equal to the average value of say the
force average value of minus DV DX and
that is the theorem that ehrenfest was
able to prove and I'll show you in just
a moment the rough idea of how you go
about proving that but let me just
indicate to you the way that this then
gives us the bridge to Newton well you
can already see that it's a bridge right
there the equation that we have for
Newton over here MD 2x DT squared minus
DV DX it looks just like this equation
but now we're doing this averaging
procedure but in particular if you say
want to go from quantum mechanics to
classical mechanics well one way of
thinking about that transition is if you
have say a wave function in quantum
mechanics that is say very spread out
then they use blue like in the animation
so a very spread out probability wave
means the particle could be at a whole
wide range of locations and that is the
strangeness the weirdness of quantum
mechanics that particle is not at a
single definite location there are many
places it could be found but if you have
a very special form of the wave function
in quantum mechanics where rather than
it being so widely spread out let's say
it looks more like this it's highly
peaked around one particular location
now the weirdness of quantum mechanics
is suppressed because the shape of the
wave tells us that there aren't a whole
lot of locations where the particle
might be found it is quite likely almost
definite that the protocol would be
found at one location in fact
make the wave ever skinnier than I am
ensuring that all of the probability is
centered over that location and
therefore I get back to a more classical
picture of the world for that very
special type of probability wave so
imagine them that I have that very
special type of probability well in that
particular case the idea of taking
average values that becomes effectively
the same thing as just the position
where the particles found because there
isn't any other non-zero value of the
probability that would spread out the
average so rather than the average being
you know the average of this and this
and this if you're just taking the
average of all these positions it's
basically that position and given that
the relationship then between this
ehrenfest equation and Newton's equation
becomes even more clear because average
values in the case of this kind of a
probability wave are very much like
actual values the actual values that we
use in Newton's second law there is one
subtlety for the folks who are following
this at a very deep level which is you
would really kind of want on the
right-hand side of ehrenfest theorem
something that looked more like the
derivative respect to X of V of the
average value of X in fact you even
really want the derivative with respect
to the average value of the at the
average value and that's not exactly
what we have we have the averaging
happening on the outside not on the
inside and that is worthy of a
discussion in its own right that would
take us a little bit too far afield
right now but just hold that in the back
of your mind if you are really thinking
about these things at a at a deep and
complete level but what I'd like to do
now is putting that subtlety to the side
just give you a sense of how it is that
Professor ehrenfest was able to derive
this equation from a starting point
where you have Schrodinger's equation
and that will give us the nice link
between Schrodinger and
and this becomes a little bit
calculational II involved so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to in two
minutes just sketch the argument right
here and then I'll give you the details
that I've already written out so I don't
have to write out all the details which
would take us quite a long time and I
think except for the few of you who
really like the gory details would be a
bit of a bore for most of you out there
so I'd like to keep this a little bit
tighter so so how does the argument go
the argument really just involves two
techniques two ingredients that are
applied over and over and over again
patiently applied mathematically so how
did the argument go then let me show you
those two ingredients so if I take the
average value the expected value of X
and we write that in the usual manner
and I'll suppress the arguments so I
don't have to write everything out size
star sine X DX and now what we want to
do is calculate first the first
derivative before getting to the second
derivative and if I calculate that first
derivative like just bring the
derivative inside the integral sign and
just change the color and make it
prettier d psystar dt sy x plus size
star d sy dt times x all this integrated
DX the X itself doesn't have a time
dependence in it the only time
dependence in the average value comes
because the wave function itself changes
over time therefore I only have two
terms on the right-hand side not three
terms and what I then do is I simply use
Schrodinger's equation to substitute for
Desai's star DT and Schrodinger's
equation to substitute for D side DT and
so if I do that I can write this out say
as the integral of now we know the
Schrodinger equation for sine from what
I recorded back over here but for size
star all I need to do is take the
complex conjugate of both sides of that
equation so I can plug in say minus H
bar square
over 2m d to size star DX squared plus v
sized star potentials real sigh X that's
my first term and then for the second
term I just play the same game size star
x now for the decide D T what I have
what I have there is minus H bar squared
over 2m D 2 sy DX squared plus V side
and then I have my X and all of this is
integrated DX all right that's step
number 1 and this will be repeated again
when we go to the second derivative what
is step 2 step 2 is I make use of the
famous results in calculus which is
known as integration by parts you know I
could have a daily equation on an
integration by parts if I want it but
I'm just gonna write down the result
just to remind you how this goes so if I
am looking at say an integral of the
form a times DB DX DX so this is just an
integral that we could have in any
calculus problem that we write down
there is a technique where I make use of
the following observation if I look at D
by DX of a times B what does that give
me
that's the a DX times B plus a DB DX
which means that the DB DX I can solve
for in this equation and write d b DX
times a is equal to d by DX of a B minus
da DX times B and so if I'm integrating
everything I know that this first term
over here is a total derivative so it
just gives me a be evaluated between the
limits of the integration which for
everything we're doing between minus
infinity and infinity minus the second
term which I can squeeze in minus da DX
time's be integrated DX now this first
term in all the applications that we
will have will vanish because a and B
will be the wave function and the wave
function has to go to zero at infinity
if we want the total probability for the
particle to be at any given location to
add up to one if it didn't go to zero at
infinity there'd be no way to normalize
the wave function so this term will
always drop out when we apply
integration by parts to the kinds of
expressions that will emerge and
therefore the bottom line is we will be
able to move a derivative in this case
it may change the color there so we're
able to move a derivative off of say
this first term over here that didn't
change my color at all to be able to
move the derivative off the first term
or I should say off the second term were
able to move it to the first term at the
expense of a minus sign so that's the
second tool that we'll use in doing our
calculation and now as promised just to
be able to wrap this up pretty quickly
and now we'll show you the actual
argument all right so you know you now
understand why I'm not writing it out in
real time in front of you I think would
be a little bit burdensome but here's
how the calculation goes and since I've
already written it out I'm simply going
to I don't know let me choose some color
that I haven't used much of Dartmouth
used every color so I'll choose hot pink
and basically for those of you that want
to quickly follow this just follow the
bouncing ball right so what do we do so
we want to take the derivative of X with
respect to T and I've already showed you
that this comes from the Schrodinger
equation I mean this comes from the
Schrodinger equation
you immediately note that this term and
this term they cancel each other out so
that drops out of the calculation and to
deal with the term over here and the
term over here we integrate each of
those by parts using the method that I
just mentioned that integration by parts
lets us take a derivative off of the
size star and say throw it on
to the other terms that we have in the
expression in this case the sign the X
and I've written it out in detail for
you in this line and in this line so if
you then slow down the video if you're
interested in the details you can check
out all the signs and so forth and you
will find that you get some nice
cancellations you do another integration
by parts on the second term bottom line
is this is what you get so this is the
derivative of the average value of
respect to time and nice simple
expression that those of you have taken
quantum mechanics you'll recognize as
nothing but the momentum operator but I
haven't followed I haven't described
that so I won't use that language but
here is our result now we're ready to
say undertake the second derivative and
I throw the M in so then we're getting
closer to M D to X DT squared of Newton
but looking at it from the Schrodinger
perspective and what we do is we now
plug in and play exactly the same game
we have our derivatives with respect to
time we can integrate this term by parts
to get the form that we have over here
we can then use Schrodinger's equation
on each of our single time derivatives
of the wave function plug in
Schrodinger's equation over here we can
then play the game of integrating by
parts so we integrate by parts on this
first term we find a nice cancellation
over here if we then do our integration
by parts on our second term first of all
this term over here will cancel against
the term that we have over here so that
drops out of the story and therefore the
only thing that's left is the result of
that integration by parts it's this term
is the only fellows left standing and
that term is nothing but if you look at
it psystar sy DV DX this is a
probability and therefore this gives us
the average value of the derivative of
the potential with respect to X there
you have it and so lo and behold this
calculation which again you can go
through more slowly if you like all of
the details are on the pages and you can
just rewind and
slow down or stop on a page if you like
but we have now gotten where I promised
we would get we have M times D to
average value of X DT squared minus DV
DX so there it is and I've already shown
you the interpretation of that as a nice
way of linking classical and quantum
physics because indeed we've recovered a
kind of average version of Newton but
starting from the quantum mechanical
Schrodinger equation following you know
it's a slightly involved but nothing
deep about the calculation approach that
was given to us in that 1927 paper by
paul ehrenfest all right to finish this
up I'll simply say there's another way
of linking classical mechanics to
quantum mechanics it comes from Richard
Feynman it makes use of what's known as
the path integral or the sum over
histories approach to quantum mechanics
I will try to take that up at some point
I mean you know so many equations so
little time right and you know I don't
know exactly which equations I'll
ultimately get to and but just so you
know there's another way of linking
classical mechanics and quantum
mechanics but this I think is a very
beautiful approach that you should bear
in mind how if a finish on this one
thought if on another planet those
scientists first found quantum mechanics
I don't know how this would happen but
imagine that they first found quantum
mechanics and then someone came along in
in that universe you know some
subversion of ehrenfest or a version of
Albert Einstein what ever they could
have taken the Schrodinger equation or
whatever they called the quantum
mechanical equation on that planet and
they could have said let's see what this
looks like if we have wave functions
that are very spiked and from the
Schrodinger equation or whatever they
call it they would have derived
classical mechanics they would have
derived what we called Newton's second
law now that's not the history of
physics on
planet we went from Newton's second law
because that's the law of you can sort
of see at work in the everyday world and
then we dug deeper and we got quantum
mechanics but the beauty of what we just
discussed in today's your daily equation
is that you can start with quantum
mechanics and extract classical
mechanics from it okay that's all I
wanted to talk about here today looking
forward to seeing you at our next
episode of your daily equation until
then take care